bonjour aujourd'hui 16 octobre bienvenue
pour une nouvelle édition de votre
journal du vendredi voici les titres la
suite de la mobilisation en faveur du
cinéma d'elancourt hier soir ce sont les
élus socialistes notamment de maurepas
qui tenait une réunion publique
eux aussi inquiets des projets de grands
complexes développées un tour ce week
end au congrès du secours populaire des
yvelines bilan perspectives à la veille
de ce rendez vous avec pascal rodier
responsable de l'association
et puis l essentiel de la semaine ce
qu'il faut retenir de l'actualité locale
entre les attaques de la droite sur la
gestion des finances de l'agglomération
par l'ancienne majorité et l'université
des maires des yvelines à port marly
bonjour pascal rodier bienvenue sur ce
journal on vous retrouve donc dans
quelques instants pour parler de votre
congrès et puis également peut-être vos
réactions à l'actualité vous êtes venu
en prêtent aujourd'hui avec l'un de vos
partenaires représentant de l' ong
hommes environnement développement à tam
a interdit au niger bonjour à vous et
donc à tout à l'heure l'actualité du
jour tout d'abord le lancement par
l'association évinoise de prévention
contre le sida hf prévention de virus
war le premier jeu interactif et ludique
sur la lutte contre la maladie s'est
ouvert de 10h à 20h cela se déroule la
place de la bastille à paris et vous
intégrerez l'argonaute et ses forces
spéciales
c'est très sérieux néanmoins rappelons
qu'aujourd'hui 30% des étudiants ne se
protège pas le pourcentage atteint même
les 39 % chez les étudiantes
écoutez jérôme andres est au micro de
williams elle donc virus soir c'est
relativement simple les gens viennent on
va les miniaturiser on va les injecter
dans une personne qui est nouvellement
donc séropositives et ça va permettre en
réalité qu'on les emmène dans
l'argonaute et donc on va les propulser
dans le corps de la personne et ils vont
pouvoir essayer et tenté de tuer le
virus du sida à coups de pistolet laser
et chaque prix tir de pistolet laser
permet effectivement donc d'avoir des
des tiers de trithérapie le virus du
sida
eh bien il est donc déguisé
en virus et il est donc dans l'arène et
c'est une arène de 250 m² gonflables
qu'on a monté aujourd'hui place de la
bastille l'idée c'est vraiment de
s'amuser et d'apprendre et de comprendre
des choses tout en s'amusant et on
oublie pas l adage sortez couverts nous
vous en parlions hier la guerre des
multiplexes se poursuit dans les
yvelines ce soir et hier soir pardon il
était plus particulièrement question du
ciné 7 à elancourt un complexe de huit
salles doit voir le jour prochainement à
maurepas dans la ville voisine elle les
conséquences pourraient être
désastreuses pour cet équipement de
quartier comme l'ont expliqué plusieurs
élus socialistes d'opposition du secteur
lors d'une réunion publique florane
parfait
la salle est comble les regards soucieux
organisées par l'opposition de maurepas
cette réunion a attiré de nombreux
habitants dans la soirée du jeudi 15
octobre
il s'interroge sur l'éventuelle
installation de deux multiplexes à
proximité et ses conséquences sur le
cinéma 17 mar le cinéma de cette marque
nous appartient
c'est notre culture on a aussi la
possibilité d'avoir des films sur
demande pour les écoles ce qu'on ne
pourra pas à voir avec le multiplexe
disons que cela dynamiserait peut-être
un peu plus le signer cette obliger les
à ce moment-là de de changer souvent le
programme ou alors de changer de façon
de travailler
l'accueil des clients également mais
sont grandes à ce grand atout est
toujours la tarification la nouveauté
pourquoi pas mais tous sont attachés au
ciné cette sortie de terre en même temps
que le quartier 17 mar dans les années
70 mettre en concurrence ça peut être un
élément moteur pour je dirais
favoriser les prix à la baisse pour
avoir une concurrence saine et avoir de
meilleurs produits etc
sauf que là on parle pas de produit on
parle de culture
si le projet de multiplexe de coignières
vient d'être refusée par la commission
nationale de l'aménagement celui de
maurepas semble bien avancé pour
certains 3 cinéma dans un tel périmètre
c'est beaucoup trop
via un double risque et d'une part la
facim à 7 mars autour un déficit soit
obligée d'arrêter mais qu'en même temps
gouttes deux trois ans le cinéma de
maurepas s'aperçoivent que huit salles
c'est beaucoup trop sur la zone et est
lui-même arrête donc sérieuse un fiasco
pour tout le monde
les débats vont continuer les travaux du
multiplexe de maurepas pourrait débuter
dès le premier semestre 2016 dont la
zone du village des loisirs société dans
le cadre de la semaine bleue à
destination des seniors plusieurs
événements étaient programmés depuis
lundi notamment à versailles la ville a
développé entre autres le thème de lits
santé à l'hôtel de ville
williams elle commercialise pilote c'est
ce bouton donc on va le fixer sur les
boîtes de médicaments donc soit
directement comme un trombone soit alors
avec à l'aide d'un élastique sur tout
type de support au soutien des flacons
les tubes on programme son ordonnance
dans son smartphone alors de prison clos
boutons c'est clair et le smartphone
sonne en rappelant la 2 1 qui peut
prendre trois cuillères à soupe de tels
médicaments jeux de mémoire alarme ou
tensiomètre ces objets ont tous un point
en commun ils sont connectés lundi à
versailles dans le cadre de la semaine
bleue autour de la santé numérique les
seniors étaient invités à découvrir ces
nouvelles technologies des appareils
innovants qui peuvent faciliter la vie
mais aussi poser quelques difficultés
d'utilisation nous avons
à l'attention d'un public senior la
volonté de les 20 tirs dans tous les
événements de la vie on veut absolument
qu'il soit à la fois bénéficier et puis
qu'ils ne soient pas victimes de ce
développement un petit peu inconsidérés
parfois un petit peu inquiétant des
nouvelles technologies conférence sur
l'innovation et démonstrations de ces
objets l'objectif n'est pas de vendre
mais de rassurer une génération qui peut
parfois se sentir éloigné de cet univers
qu'elle ne maîtrise pas oui ça me donne
envie
sauf que ce n'est pas les moyens c'est
certain très utile surtout tu sais ce
que je recherche pour ma mémoire que qui
file des objets qui répondent à un
besoin réel pour les seniors ou leurs
familles seulement voilà le prix
généralement trop élevés peuvent souvent
un problème d'accessibilité bien
vieillir à domicile en étant connecté ce
n'est pas encore donné à tout le monde
invité de ce vendredi pascal redit le
président du secours populaire des
yvelines et moi mais dax air de l'omg
hii d'état matt d'univers tout
simplement l un de vos partenaires on va
évoquer votre actualité
auparavant on vient de voir un reportage
consacré à la semaine bleue destination
des seniors des personnes âgées
quel regard vous avez là dessus sachant
que le secours populaire intervient
aussi auprès des personnes âgées
mais en fait depuis quelques années le
constat que l'on fait nous c'est qu'il
ya de plus en plus de seniors qui
repousse la porte du secours populaire
pour subvenir aux besoins vitaux ils
n'en sont pas encore au smartphone à la
tablette et aux équipements connectés et
ça fait déjà maintenant trois quatre ans
qu'on développe de plus en plus des
journées de sortie pour briser l'
isolement
essayer de renouer le contact avec un
public qui osent pas trop non plus qui
garde sa dignité et puis qui osent pas
trop dire quelles sont ces difficultés
donc et ça s'amplifie à une demande de
plus en plus forte
mammeri oui et bat pour vous donner un
ordre d'idée l'année dernière pour le 31
décembre on avait fait un réveillon pour
50 personnes
c'était la deuxième édition et cette
année on passe à 80 parce que on essaye
de répondre un petit peu la demande et
il ya des structures locales qui compte
à peu près 15 % des foyers aidés qui
sont des personnes de plus de 65 ans
donc ça ça n'est pas magique demain se
tiendra à votre congrès annuel organisé
au château de versailles à quoi sert ce
rendez-vous justement à faire le bilan
il n'y allait pas pour faire du tourisme
c'est sur château on va quand même
visité le château à la cause mais en
fait le secours populaire fête ses 70
ans
cette année et tous les deux ans en fait
notre association connaît le rythme du
renouvellement de sa direction et de ses
structures locales
jusqu'à ces structures départementales
et à sa structure nationale donc tous
les deux ans entre octobre et novembre
on se livre à cet exercice qui comme
vous le disait 10 y est un temps de
bilan et puis un temps de perspective
donc c'est pour ça qu'on fait un rapport
moral d'activités un rapport
d'orientation et on se livre à beaucoup
des changes pour décider ensemble des
points sur lesquels mettre l'accent
et puis on prépare aussi notre
délégation départementale qui
participera au congrès national et donc
cette année se tiendra à marseille sur
le bilan justement vous avez été
beaucoup sollicité récemment par rapport
à l'arrivée des migrants dont on a
beaucoup parlé dans les médias est ce
que aujourd'hui encore ces migrants
arrivent on en parle moins et quel est
votre travail vous les accompagnez
toujours alors en fait dans les yvelines
on n'est pas débordé faut bien le dire
de demandes
je pense que c'est aussi parce que il
n'y a pas eu comme dans le val d'oise
par exemple de centre de grands centres
qui ont accueilli plusieurs dizaines
voire centaines de personnes les
populations quand même tendance à se
concentrer sur paris et la petite
couronne et donc nous au niveau des
yvelines
il y aura certainement un décalage et
les on sait qu'il ya des personnes qui
ont commencé à arriver par le biais du
115 dans les hôtels et donc on va venir
on va voir venir dans nos structures
locales de manière un petit peu plus
décalé et malheureusement je pense que
ça va durer quelques mois voire quelques
années puisque c'est pas parce qu'on en
parle un peu moins
à la télé que les gens arrêtent de venir
le problème reste le même
il est loin d'être réglée et donc on
continue d'avoir de plus en plus de
demandes dans les permanences d'accueil
de la part de ce type de public et ce
n'est qu'une de vos activités parce que
si vous intervenez en france vous
intervenez aussi à l'étranger ce qui te
l'a amené à parler du niger notamment on
va peut-être commencer par parler de
votre ong justement si vous pouviez nous
la présenter un petit peu le travail que
vous menez oui j'ai m'appelle moi-même
d'accès gsid secrétaire général du roi
c'est d'administration dlg nigériennes
ont violement développement que nous
faisons des actions sur la santé
l'éducation l'amélioration des
conditions de vie des femmes nous
faisons des actions en faveur des jeunes
nous faisons des actions et pour la paix
parce que vous savez que nous sommes
dans une zone où il ya beaucoup de
conflits au sein aide avec de nouveaux
coffres du qu'on connaît avec les
nouveaux acteurs du conflit qui sont
chez nous donc nous essayons de
sensibiliser les gens pour la paix ces
derniers temps avec le secours populaire
français nous avons quinze ans des
partenariats et nous sommes venus
participer au congrès de secours
populaire pour faire les témoignages des
du partenariat qu'on a des secours
populaire français
quels sont les types d'action vous
développé en partenariat justement de
quelle manière vous venez en aide à
cette année alors ces dernières années
on a beaucoup pacs et notre soutien sur
la cré m
le fonçage de puits et puis maraîchers
des puits pastoraux des puits villageois
donc très rapidement les puits
maraîchers c'est pour développer le
jardinage familiale les puits pastoraux
c'est pour permettre d'étendre les zones
de pâture et faire en sorte que le petit
bétail essentiellement un puissent être
mieux alimenter et donc de ce fait
produire plus de lait produire plus
d'effet positif pour les populations et
les puits villageois sont des puits un
petit peu plus sophistiquée souvent
fermées avec des roues à aubes des roues
à main qui permettent d'avoir une eau de
bien meilleure qualité qui diminue les
maladies notamment infantile liée à une
ou un petit peu plus souillé
donc ça c'est un axe mais dans tout le
cours de nos de nos longues années de
deux projets communs on a contribué à la
mise en place d'une troupe de théâtre
itinérante pour faire de la prévention
sur le vih et
les maladies sexuellement transmissibles
on a contribué à l'équipement de
quelques écoles en fournitures scolaires
on a aussi apporter notre solidarité à
des périodes de crise en finançant des
programmes d'urgence permettant la
mobilité la population de se mobiliser
en contrepartie de pouvoir bénéficier
tout soit d'infrastructures pour leur
village pour les protéger des
inondations notamment ou à consolider
des terres des terres agricoles
voilà c'est ce type de ce type d'action
que nous faisons j'en ai probable oublié
il y en a d'autres d'ailleurs aussi à
venir parce que vous l'avez dit si vous
êtes venu c'est pour assister au congrès
et puis c'est aussi l occasion de lancer
d'autres projets aujourd'hui vous vous
évoquez quelles possibilités quels sont
les besoins tout simplement
oui mais donc on a fait un grand projet
d'accès à l'eau et mais c'est pascal
bridy l'aï évoqué tantôt et nous avons
réalisé et 5 5 4 puis 5 4 me dont 88
mari chez nf puis et pastoraux et sept
puits villageois donc maintenant et que
ce programme est réalisé
nous sommes venir réfléchir avec les
secours populaire français
comment est maintenant et contribuer
efficacement à l'autonomisation des
populations et des populations du nord
niger qui sont une des populations
touareg qui sont qui étaient des
éleveurs mais avec les changements des
effets du changement climatique sont
obligées de s'adapter et au monde est
accompagné d'un dbz attentes
d'adaptation au changement
climatique donc ces mesures c'est
surtout et travailler avec les enfants
la restauration des terres à travers la
mise en place des pépinières et aussi
des femmes parce qu'il ya du groupement
des femmes travaillent beaucoup avec le
groupement des femmes coma et amener les
femmes à contribuer à travers la mise en
place des pépinières et des plantations
d'arbres à la restauration des terres
pour permettre et la pratique d'une
activité principale qui sont des loges
et les marichelles sans l'aide des
associations comme le secours populaire
vous ne pourriez pas mener à bien vos
différentes missions justement et ça
sera difficile même si on a la volonté
même si on peut mobiliser les
populations et il nous faut des moyens
financiers et ses moyens financiers
c'est ça qui manque et nous travaillons
à ça pour la richesse de mois est
financée avec des organisations comme
des soucoupes beaucoup d'air france tian
témoignage important parce qu on entend
assez peu parlé de l'action du secours
populaire à l'étranger mais si c'est
vrai et pourtant
d
et son origine le secours populaire a
toujours marqué cette attention à ce qui
se passe au delà des frontières puisque
dans les frontières ça ne sont ce ne
sont jamais que des constructions
humaines et la solidarité
c'est une réponse au racisme
la xénophobie l'exaltation des
différences et donc nous on est plutôt
sur le schéma inverse vous voyez donc
dans les années 60 quand il ya eu les
grands mouvements de décolonisation le
secours populaire était aux côtés des
populations à madagascar mais dans
d'autres pays notamment et les liens à
madagascar par exemple dure depuis cette
période là avant même la création du
secours populaire français il existait
le secours populaire de france et des
colonies et quand les personnes ont été
marqués par le conflit
enfin par la guerre d'espagne le secours
populaire aidé les républicains qui
étaient déplacés dans le sud de la
france donc en fait il ya toujours eu
une dimension internationale de nos
actions ça fait des années et des années
qu'on est présents au liban
ces derniers temps quand on nous
interpeller sur la situation des
réfugiés syriens
ça fait des années qu'on intervient sur
les zones proches puisque avant
d'arriver jusqu'en europe
beaucoup de ces personnes là qui sont
déplacées par des conflits interminables
inextricable pour certains restent dans
la zone périphérique est donc là pour le
secours populaire en fait on fait pas de
distinction
entre la solidarité en france et la
solidarité dans le monde ont fait
techniquement pour les appels aux dons
puisque c'est des contraintes qui sont
légitimes c'est les contraintes par
rapport à l'appel à la générosité du
public mais dans l'esprit du secours
populaire il n'y a pas de distinction
entre entre la france et le monde
puisque dans les articles fondateur
l'article 20 des statuts on dit que on
regroupe des personnes de toutes
opinions politiques ou philosophiques
dans le but de pratiquer la solidarité
vis-à-vis d'eux ou à profit des
personnes victimes de catastrophes
naturelles de conflits armés
de la misère et on dit pas en france ça
s'arrête pas aux portes pour ça merci
d'être venu sur ce plateau merci à tous
les deux je rappelle que le congrès du
secours populaire se déroule ce week-end
nous aurons bien évidemment l'occasion
elle d'y revenir en début de semaine
prochaine dans notre journal merci
encore à vous on passe comme chaque
vendredi au résumé de la semaine
ce pas là une entreprise yvelinoise
labellisé made in france le groupe
christ située dans les yvelines s'est vu
remettre cette distinction aujourd'hui
sur son site de badens ville pour
l'occasion deux anciens ministres
arnaud montebourg et yves jégo et p 13
ans a le patriotisme économique a un
sens faut l'encourager je suis un
militant du produire en france du made
in france
je suis venu le dire ici chez krys
félicité et encouragé l'entreprise ses
dirigeants ses salariés ses cadres le
comité interministériel de la sécurité
routière s'est réuni au mois de fin
s'est réuni le vendredi dernier la c'est
la première fois du quinquennat certains
estiment qu'il était temps qu'ils se
réunissent compte tenu des mauvais
chiffres de la de la mortalité fin de la
de la sécurité routière en particulier
mois de juillet mois d'août et il en
faut aussi du contrôle et de la
répression
le tout est que l'équilibré soit
maintenue entre la partie prévention qui
est fait par des associations telles que
la nôtre en particulier
et puis la partie répression et contrôle
qui est fait bien évidemment par les
forces de l'ordre et par la justice et
l'hôpital privé de trappes se met au
rose l'association admis était cet après
midi dans un établissement pour
sensibiliser au dépistage du cancer du
sein
toute la semaine dans le cadre du mois
d'octobre rose des événements sont
prévus chaque année en france ce sont 49
mille femmes qui apprennent qu'elles
sont touchées par cette maladie
la nouvelle majorité de l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines vient de
délivrer une conférence de presse pour
présenter le résultat de plusieurs
audits internes des accusations lourdes
contre l'ancienne équipe de gauche ça
fait quelques années que je vois ici
vous savez le copinage politique c'est
terrible bien voir un vrai débat mais
avec des vrais documents sur qu'est ce
qu'ils reprochaient / / / sur quels
éléments et pas à partir de graphiques
donc un sens pas sourcée pas chiffrées
sur lequel on peut faire dire tout et
n'importe quoi entre maurepas et
coignières la guerre des cinémas est
déclarée chaque ville a son projet de
multiplexe mais seulement l'un des deux
pourra voir le jour
la question semble avoir été tranchée
mercredi dernier en faveur de maurepas
lors de la commission nationale
d'aménagement commercial
match de gala hier soir au stade léo
lagrange de poissy les anciens champions
du monde 98
laurent blanc didier deschamps fabien
barthez et christian karembeu ont
rechaussé les crampons à l'occasion d'un
match exhibition entre le variétés club
de france et la sncf
ça ferait plaisir de se retrouver il y
avait du monde tout est parfait vous
êtes senti comment vous y sentez
vieillissant pour les novices
est-ce que vous avez quelques exemples
de champignons qui sont comestibles sans
danger alors justement jérôme affaires
que l'on a entendu a été faire d'une
récolte le matin même et dans sa
collecte
il y avait des champignons comestibles
comme le bol et à pied rouge dont la
chair bluy très rapidement attention
d'autres champignons ont la chair bleue
y sente ce n'est pas un signe de
comestibilité on peut trouver aussi la
langue de boeuf qui est légèrement les
gels gélatineuse sur le dessus et c'est
l'un des rares champignons que l'on peut
consommer crus les maires des yvelines
se réunissent et c'est aujourd'hui à
port marly comme chaque année au
programme de cette université
la diminution des dotations de l'état
les inquiétudes que cela engendre
connu pour ses reprises comme mon amie
la rose qui lui ont valu une victoire de
la musique en 1999
natacha atlas retrouve cette fois ci son
public en anglais avec de nouvelles
créations expression d'une intimité
profonde un retour sur scène avec
émotion voilà pour ce zapping de l'info
samedi 17 octobre restera-t-il dans l
histoire du rugby la france face à la
nouvelle zélande en coupe du monde 6
pour les hommes de philippe saint-andré
la tâche sera ardue ce sont les sections
féminines qui se portent en tout cas
plutôt bien l'engouement est réel les
performances également le reportage de
michael et demi de mêlée redoublement de
passes plaquage ce mercredi ses joueuses
de rugby rhône herbe n'ont pas ménagé
leurs efforts au stade de porsche
antenne de versailles pour la troisième
année consécutive un tournoi était
organisé par le rugby-club de la ville
et les associations sportives de
collèges des yvelines objectif
développer cette discipline chez les
filles transparent ce sont en fait les
professeurs qui demande plus de dates de
compétition pour les filles car on sait
que la pratique ça aide les filles à a
mieux joué
donc les ce sont les professeurs qui
sont qui nous sollicitent en fait pour
faire des tournois et nous à versailles
en est ouvert sur le développement du
rôle du soldat les collèges de bois
d'arcy de carrières sous poissy du chéné
de noisy le roi et de magnanville ont
participé à ce tournoi
au total une soixantaine de jeunes âgés
de 11 à 15 ans se sont inscrits pour la
compétition 20 de plus que l'année
dernière
je pense que la coupe du monde à aider
un peu plus cette année justement a
rassemblé plus de filles au niveau des
associations sportives
après généralement le rugby on y vient
pour l'esprit camaraderie donc entre
copines
et puis pour le jeu c'est un jeu qui est
assez dynamique
avant mes frères et ses raisons faisait
après j'ai pris leur exemple et j'ai vu
c'était bien c'est bien de jouer avec
des filles ça change de jouer avec des
garçons c'est mieux que les filles
fassent quand même diminué parce que
c'est pas spécialement un sport de
brutes comparé à ce qu'on peut dire dans
la catégorie des minimes les barbarians
une équipe composée de joueuses de
montigny-le-bretonneux de versailles de
conflans remporter la victoire
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
quatrième édition un mot de la
programmation de nos confrères de radio
sensations nicolas kirilow vite se
reçoit pour son hebdo politique nathalie
arthaud tête de liste lutte ouvrière aux
régionales en île de france est à 18
heures à dimanche extrait de cette
intrigue aussi qui vous ravir et porter
des idées pour peser sur le débat
nous n'allons pas adapter notre discours
aux sondages
nous avons des convictions nous les
mettons dans son vous crédite de 1%
d'intentions de vote pour l'instant ce
que c'est chose à laquelle vous faites
attention est ce qu'il ya un score aussi
kivu ravirait pour porter pour le second
tour pourquoi pas des idées pour peser
sur le débat nous nous n'allons pas
adapter notre discours aux sondages
nous avons des convictions nous les
mettons en avant tout simplement et nous
sommes pas des girouettes je sais bien
que beaucoup dessine des décide de
leur programme comme ça on en écoutant
les sondages et puis alors du coup ils
partent dans une direction c'est vous
savez c'est un petit centre commercial
un qui veut vendre sa camelote va mettre
en avant tel ou tel aspect etc
mais nous nous avons des convictions ne
sommes pas des girouettes et nous les
mettons en avant
voilà la suite à écouter sur radio
sensations à dimanche
quant à nous le journal revient à lundi
avec floriane parfait la semaine
prochaine il sera question notamment de
l'agitation qui règne autour des pmi le
conseil départemental longtemps
mutualiser les moyens des différentes
antennes pour optimiser l'efficacité
certaine vont donc fermé les élus de
gauche concernées s'inquiète vous voyez
quelques images des précédentes
mobilisations et nous recevront en
plateau la conseillère départementale et
les républicains du canton de montigny
guyancourt laurence trochut et puis en
fin de semaine nous recevons également
les étudiants en droit de l'université
de versailles saint quentin en yvelines
pour un tout autre sujet et chaque année
il reconstitue un grand procès de
l'histoire une mise en situation devant
à la cour dans les moindres détails seul
le verdict peut éventuellement changer
il travaille actuellement sur le dossier
du tueur en série américain ted bundy
je vous souhaite néanmoins un excellent
week-end bon début de vacances n'oubliez
pas vos idées à loisir dans le
département c'est avec le 7-8 week end
sur notre antenne dans un instant avec
mélanie poker